Vocabulary, active vocabulary,
passive vocabulary.
When do we know a word?
This comes up all the time.
You know, I've often said that the
most important task in language
journey is acquiring words.
Of course phrases are always, are also
important, but phrases consist of words,
and I use the word acquire in the sense
of developing a passive vocabulary.
So I, for example, saw a comment on, on
my YouTube channel here from one of my
listeners who said, The most important
thing is your active vocabulary.
And, and often people say,
you know, if you don't use it,
you have to use it right away.
If you don't use it right away, you,
you won't learn it, you'll lose it.
And I have always resisted that for
a simple reason, and that is that
if you are taught something today,
and you're tested on it today or
tomorrow, you may in fact remember it.
That doesn't mean that you have acquired
that vocabulary item, doesn't mean that
you will remember it a few months later.
I've, uh, stressed always that
the process of acquisition is
much le much fuzzier than that.
We're kind of putting
words into our brain.
Some of which activate
sooner, some activate later.
I don't make much of a distinction
between active and passive vocabulary.
If anything, I believe in accumulating
as much passive vocabulary as possible
because that is the first step and the key
step to eventually being able to use them.
And if you don't have this passive
vocabulary, if you don't have
comprehension, it's very difficult
to have conversations with
people because most people, if...
especially you're speaking to native
speakers, they will have a much larger
vocabulary than you have and even in
your own language, you have a much larger
passive vocabulary than active vocabulary.
So the passive vocabulary is, is
an important part of, you know,
where you are in the language.
And we shouldn't just focus on
what we are able to use today,
may not be able to use tomorrow.
Uh, it's far more important just
to continue filling your brain with
words that will eventually activate.
Also when it comes to like, when can
I claim that I have this passive,
even the passive vocabulary?
Uh, I was talking to someone the other day
who said, maybe, you know, at LingQ you
should, uh, you know, have some kind of
an indicator of when we have learned, for
example, uh, the names of family members,
which in some languages is quite complex.
Or the names of the colors.
Well, even leaving aside the fact that
those things are very difficult to learn
and not all that useful out of context,
you'll only acquire them gradually.
But even if you...
how do you know that?
Just because I saw, you know, if
I'm on LingQ and I saw this, uh,
word which represented, you know, my
mother-in-law and my, you know, somebody
else's side of the family or whatever.
Some of these languages have very
complicated words for cousins and
brothers and older and nephews.
But even if I remember on one
occasion, it doesn't mean that I'll
remember them on another occasion.
Far more important is to keep track of,
and this is what we do at LingQ, the
fact that people are continuing to expose
themselves to the language, are continuing
to, you know, pile words and phrases
into their brain increasingly creating
these sort of neural connections, which
at some point will a, create therefore
an active bit of vocabulary that you
just naturally recognize you, not because
you're tested on it, but because you
naturally start to recognize it in your.
Reading and listening, uh, often that'll
mean at LingQ that it's a white word now
it's no longer highlighted in yellow.
You just naturally know what it means.
You don't even think about it.
Or at least you know it insofar
as a certain context is concerned.
You may not be aware of the full range
of meaning of that word, but you at
least are aware of it in that context.
Eventually, as you see that word in
different contexts, you'll become
aware of the sort of broader scope of
meaning of that word, but testing you
on, you know, what does this mean?
Now to me is not a, um, a meaningful,
uh, sort of measure of where you
are, but it is a sort of reflection
of, of how languages are taught at
school or constantly being tested so
that the teacher can show the parents
and the school administrators that
the kids are learning something.
And after 10 years of that kind of
language instruction, very often the
kids still can't speak the language.
Far better to just load it
all in there, load it all in
there, let it sort itself out.
When the opportunity arises, when
the need arises, lo and behold things
start to activate both the active
vocabulary, which was hiding there
somewhere, and the passive vocabulary.
So just a bit of a, sort of a, it's,
it's very much a theme that I've, uh,
you know, referenced in the past and
that is, let's not be too concerned
about like, do you really know the word?
Do you know the full scope
of meaning of the word?
Are you able to use the word?
Don't worry about that.
Just keep on shoveling it into your brain,
and eventually you will find that you'll
be able to understand these words and some
of them, but always a smaller subset you
will be able to use when the need arises.
Thanks for listening.